decisions to adapt our lines for the
future
we agreed on the fundamental shift in
our deterrence and defence
we agreed to invite finland and sweden
to join our alliance
and we agreed on long-term support for
ukraine
we agreed nato's new strategic concept
we agreed to
step up
in the fight against climate change
and to establish a new
1 billion
innovation fund
we agreed to invest more in nato and to
increase nato's common funded budgets
and we agreed to deepen our
relationships with some of the alliance
closest partners
not least in the indo pacific
our final
session at the madrid summit focused on
threats and challenges from the middle
east
north africa and the sahel
insecurity in these regions has a direct
impact
on the security of all allies
and our new strategic concept identifies
terrorism as one of the main threats to
our security
today
we reviewed our progress in the fight
against terrorism
in all its forms and manifestations
and we confirmed our commitment to
continue the fight with determination
and solidarity
including through intelligence sharing
and support for our partners
nato's training mission in iraq is
helping to prevent the return of isis
for the first time we have just agreed a
defense capacity billing package for
mauritania
helping to address
border security irregular migration and
terrorism
we have also agreed additional capacity
building support for tunisia
and to continue supporting
jordan
we also addressed the global food crisis
which is a direct result of russia's
invasion of ukraine
the impact is severe including on some
of the world's most vulnerable people
food prices are hitting record heights
and many countries depend on ukraine
for substantial wheat and other food
imports
so allies discuss their efforts to
mitigate the crisis
and get grain out of ukraine by land and
on sea
we also
addressed how russia and china continue
to seek political economic and military
gain across our southern neighborhood
both moscow and beijing are using
economic leverage coercion and hybrid
approaches to advance their interest in
the region
so today we discussed how to address
this growing challenge
including with even more support for
nato's partners in the region
we face the most serious security
situation in decades
but we are rising to the challenge with
unity and resolve
the decisions you have taken in madrid
will ensure that our alliance continue
to preserve
preserve peace prevent conflict and
protect our people
and our values
europe and north america standing
together in nato
let me
close by thanking prime minister sanchez
the spanish government
and the people of madrid for hosting
this historic summit
an excellent way to mark 40 years of
spain's membership in nato
we will meet again
for a nato submit in vilnius lithuania
next year
and with that i'm ready to take your
questions
we'll start with cnbc
secretary general hadley gamble with
cnbc news can i ask you to respond
directly to the comments we heard
overnight from russian president
vladimir putin he essentially suggested
that
sweden and finland joining the alliance
would require some kind of response from
the russian government he said that if
there were nato weapons systems placed
in those two countries that that would
precipitate a direct response from his
government and could i also ask you to
respond directly to him and when he says
that at this point ukraine should
surrender completely and all he wants is
the donbass region
as we decide today
to support ukraine to make sure that
ukraine prevails as an independent
sovereign state in europe
and the president putin's brutal war
against ukraine is absolutely
unacceptable it's causing a lot of
death damage
for the ukrainian people but it also has
ramifications
over the whole world not really not
least because of the increase in food
prices so it's a president putin that
should
withdraw its forces and end this war
immediately by stopping attacking a
democratic sovereign nation and causing
so much suffering in ukraine
when it comes to finland and sweden phil
and sweden are severe nations and they
have the right to choose their own path
and to join nato we have welcomed them
into our alliance and we are of course
prepared for any eventuality
but at the same time i think what we see
now in ukraine
demonstrates that
russia is now fully focused on that
war
and
and therefore also we are also taking
note of the messages from moscow
actually
that
it doesn't change so much much that finn
and sweden are joining the alliance
while they have communicated different
messages from moscow on that issue
the most important thing for us is that
finland sweden
will become members of the alliance we
are there to protect all allies and of
course also finland and sweden and we
are prepared for all eventualities
okay
we'll go to swedish radio
now you will
apparently have another two member
states sweden and finland what kind of
challenges will you have in terms of
unity
you have a lot of differences in way of
these
groups of member states we're talking
about
economics politics military power and
the second question if i may
when will you sign the accession
protocol
thank you
the political decision uh the real
decision to invite finland and sweden to
join nato was taken at the summit
yesterday
so that decision has been taken
and
and and then we will do the formal
signing of the accession protocol on
tuesday
with the presence of the
swedish and finnish foreign ministers
but but the reality the decision has
uh been decided already with their
political decision by all the leaders uh
yesterday at this uh madrid summit
then i think on the question of unity i
think
sometimes it's
easy to you know confuse two very
different things
nato has never been
and will never
become a monolithic organization
where 30 and 32 allies agree on every
issue we are 32 different countries with
different political parties
in government and different culture
different history different geography
from both southern atlantic so you will
always find differences
and for me that's not the weakness
that's just an expression of
the the strength of nato that we are
democratic nations with a variety of
different opinions on many issues
so if you define unity as a monolithic
organization we will never be that
but if you define unity as something
completely different
that well we are different but we are
able to unite
and stand together on the core issues to
protect and defend each other then
we have actually demonstrated unity and
resolved at this summit as we have done
for more than seven years
um
providing the security preserving peace
preventing war uh and sending a clear
message to any potential adversary that
we are there to protect and defend all
allies and as long as that is credible
which is his nato then no allah will be
attacked
nato's main purpose is to prevent war by
having credible deterrents
okay dpa
has a job in press adrian dpa
secretary general you said that leaders
agreed to invest more in nato and to
increase common funding
can you please tell us by what
percentage nato will increase its common
funding budgets and the second question
if i may do you support the idea of
bringing western maine battle tanks to
ukraine thank you
we support the fdo bringing
a lot of advanced
equipment including also western modern
equipment
many different types of equipment we
have scene announcements uh and
we there was a new announcement at this
summit so and actually nato now has
a task to help
ukraine transition from old soviet area
equipment to
modern
nato standard
equipment
and of course we are not a list of
equipment we will rule out or exclude
from
from from that
ukraine needs
a wide range of modern
heavy
nato standard equipment and that's a
message also from this uh this summit
then
on common funding
uh we are we are following up uh on the
decision we made in principle last year
that we need to invest more together
um uh because in a more dangerous world
we need to strengthen what we do
together in nato
and we have decided a trajectory for
common funding up to 2030
the
specific figures will be decided in the
yearly or annual budgets
what i can say is that the agreement we
have reached today
represent uh represents a considerable
significant increase
in nato's common funded budgets
and that will enable us to invest more
together in
pre-position equipment in hardened
shelters in infrastructure
and to ensure that
we can plug and play
capabilities
together in nato
also with more commander control and
also to more provide more support to our
partners and also to have more exercises
so it is a significant considerable
increase in nato's common funded budget
and agreed trajectory towards
2030.
thank you secretary general
from spanish newspaper
first of all
would you give us more
impressions about the spanish
organization of the summit as a hosted
nation and secondly
could you clarify if nato's position
regarding celta and malaysia the two
autonomous cities of spain has changed
anything after the new strategic concept
above all regarding to the article 5.
thank you very much
the hosting by the spanish government of
this
summit has been perfect impeccable
excellent
and uh all allies expressed a gratitude
to spain
uh for hosting us in madrid a beautiful
city at the royal palace and at the
prado museum and then at this
conference here where all the facilities
have been in place
and actually provided the best possible
framework for a historic nato summit a
summit that
has taken a
transformative decisions for our
alliance we have the new madrid nato
strategic concept and we have all the
other decisions so so we are extremely
grateful to uh to the spanish government
to pedro sanchez the prime minister and
and the people of madrid in the way uh
you have hosted us and also it i think
it demonstrates that spain is really a
highly valued and important ally and
it's a very good way for spain to
to celebrate to mark the
40th anniversary of your membership
um on um which territories um nato
protects and south america uh well as
nato state to protect all allies against
any threat
at the end of the day it will always be
a political decision to invoke article 5
but rest assured nato is there to
protect and defend all allies
politico
thanks very much david herzenhorn with
politico europe uh secretary general
throughout the uh summit and in the
strategic concept we hear echoes of the
cold war but of course the nuclear
nonproliferation architecture has fallen
away we have unprecedented numbers of
troops on the eastern flank uh a hot war
not a cold war in ukraine has the world
entered an era that is even more
dangerous than the cold war and based on
your discussions with leaders you have a
sense that there's consensus and unity
around what are the red lines that
russia must not cross to avoid a direct
conflict
we live in a more dangerous world
and we live in a more unpredictable
world
and we live in a world where we have
actually hot war going on in europe
uh with
the large-scale
military operations we haven't seen
in europe since the second world war
and of course this is uh
imposing suffering on the ukrainian
people
and we see it every day and we pay
tribute to the courage to their
um
bravery um and we also convey that
message to president zelinski when he
addressed the the summit
at the same time we also know that this
can get worse
because if this becomes a full scale
war
between russia and nato
then we see suffering damage death
destruction
at the scale which is much much worse
than what we see in ukraine today and
therefore nato for mentally has two
tasks
one is to provide support to ukraine
nato and italians
provide
unprecedented support ukraine we are
stepping up
and we agree the pakistan at this summit
but we also have a
core responsibility of course to prevent
escalation beyond ukraine
and that's the reason why nato is not a
part of the conflict on the ground we
support our
highly valued partner
ukraine but we're not part of the
conflict and also why
we have so significantly increased our
presence in the eastern part of alliance
with more than forty thousand two
pounder directly into command to remove
any room for miscalculation
misunderstanding
uh in moscow about uh our readiness to
protect every inch of nato territory and
that's that's nato's core responsibility
to to to to make sure that there is no
misunderstanding in the minds of any
adversary that if they do anything like
what russia has done to
to to to georgia in 2008 or ukraine now
that will trigger the full response from
the whole alliance
and that's the main message and and and
that is credible and that's the reason
why we are preventing attack and
preserving peace for nato allies close
to one billion people
uh the last question we'll go to
deutsche ballet npr
hi thank you terry schultz with deutsche
welle um mr secretary general you said
that allies had spoken about how to help
mitigate food insecurity and and the
the spreading of hunger but what did
they decide is is this nato's role and
what can you do and could you also
address these reports that the russians
have left
for whatever reasons snake island will
this help free up uh shipping routes
thank you
um
so
nato allies so first of all i think it's
important that nato allies meet
and
uncoordinate and discuss and exchange
views and compare notes on the different
efforts that nato allies are involved in
to try to get more grain out of ukraine
to get food out of ukraine
second it's also important just to
convey the message that
contrary to what president putin and
actuals of china and now are telling the
world
through different disinformation
campaigns
that that
this food crisis is not caused by nato
sanctions it's caused by president
putin's war and the best way to end the
food crisis is to end the war and
president putin can end the war tomorrow
by rejoining his forces
then different allies are involved in
different ways
um
turkey plays a key role in trying to
facilitate some kind of agreement
um also greece announced that they are
ready to make available ships to get
grain out of ukraine
and other allies are involved in
different diplomatic efforts to get some
kind of agreement
to allow ships to sail
with food wheat
over the black sea
then
lithuania
other countries
also
updated us on their efforts to
romania and other countries operators on
their efforts to expand their own land
capacity by
a railway to transport more
food on land
it's very hard to compensate fully what
we can transport by ships but online is
also way and and several nato allies are
engaged in in that
and of course the most of nato's role is
to protect and defend allies uh and to
ensure and to create a space for them
to operate and that's what we do
thank you very much this concludes the
last press conference
of the secretary general for the summit
so you've heard from the nato secretary
general jens stoltenberg answering a few
questions we are expecting to hear from
britain's prime minister boris johnson
very shortly so we will take you to that
as soon as he speaks but let's just uh
sum up some of the things that mr
stoltenberg was saying describing the
nato summit in madrid as transformative
as he brought it to an end he said we
faced the most serious security
situation in decades but a rising to the
challenge with unity and resolve clearly
support for ukraine was paramount in
what he had to say there also talked
about finland and sweden joining nato
and they will send their nato
accession protocol next tuesday um
clearly he's a number of times said
the way to stop the war in ukraine is
for
vladimir putin to pull out his troops he
mentioned pull out from all uh tomorrow
um he also talks about nato leaders
discussing how to address the growing
challenge of russia and china seeking in
his words political
economic and military gain using
economic leverage coercion and hybrid
approaches so let's just focus on what
he had to say about
vladimir putin telling him to pull his
troops out of ukraine